don't put your [ __ ] hand out yet can
i give you a saving grace can i give you
a saving grace
okay before we left
he said a lot of stuff about it but you
can see
and the scissor bros up
yeah
but one of the things that i did yeah
before we left because i asked him i
said hey do you have any influence
on the high school hall of fame
and he goes i do know some people he
knows the board
so this is what i said
this is what i said don't just hear me
fellow brother i thought of this
wait
let me just get this straight okay
you're gonna be on the shoulder
do you want to make me cry right now no
no really yeah cause if you tell me that
i'm going to be on the board and i'm
going to be in the hall of fame i will
start to cry right now the scissor bros
are going to make that happen oh you
guys are going to broker that deal he
already emailed him i already emailed
him i
have a beautiful email with your list of
credits and why you should be considered
yeah we're waiting on a response yeah
this is real this is real though he says
he has influence on the board you are so
funny yeah
and you're going to be in the hall of
fame of poway
where
okay you know here's where i'm not here
please help me baby
well forget tom it's but as we know with
everything else it's all who you know in
that in that field and he has he's a
pillar of the community there and i
asked him i was like is there any way
like
okay yes that being said this is the
closest we've gotten i'm just saying
it's kind of happening it's gonna happen
i have my response to coach branstadter
okay with all the information
okay okay okay think about it please
think about it i already just did no
really thinking he tells me to think
about it all the time
all right now go
okay hold on call him cochi no
voice or reason yeah
all right
it's me bob
let me just hurry
dear kochie
it's me bob
hi pretty good
um i want to say from the bottom of my
heart i'm sorry that
in my senior year
that i chose not to
participate in the wrestling program
um i felt like i was focusing on
my sobriety and who i am as a person and
trying to figure out what this whole
thing life is
but in retrospect i do apologize i also
want to thank you for your influence
right because you're the first man i've
i've seen harry
harry knuckles
he had harry knuckles
no honestly i remember as a kid you
remember yeah yeah i remember him like
you know because i'd be like on the
bottom like drink couch yeah and you're
good no you gotta grab the wrist like
this right so you put his hand on over
the other guy's wrist and i would see
his hairy knuckles
and i would go i remember thinking of
myself i go i've never seen that before
that's cool right so
you're my first hairy knuckle experience
right
you're also somebody i was scared of but
i looked up to and i think that you're a
true champion of all time okay and i
also want to say that if you can help me
facilitate this hall of fame situation
right that my gratitude will go
so deep
towards you and your family
and to your bloodline
right we'll have a framed picture of you
and i would fight for your bloodline wow
right
and um
is that good so love keep going i love
it fantastic i love it so love dearly
love right
cochi
i mean heart heart right
and put in quotes
bobs
little bobs
thank you so much for doing that yeah
now i want to say something to you yeah
what
thank you
[Music]
thank you so much
jeremiah jeremiah
because what you've done
okay
is you've created a little monster here
what my brother what are you doing let
me let me finish dude think about it
really think about it well really think
about it yeah i want to give you a
[ __ ] compliment
okay okay okay all right breathe no i'm
not breathed no
yeah you got me an xxl what the [ __ ]
he's some me
ralphie may over all of a sudden all
right all right all right continue i
love you okay continue
by the way i just want to say little
props i did [ __ ] largo for the first
time this week yes
what is largely describe what that is to
the viewers and listeners we a lot of
people are the viewers and listeners we
have the internet and they don't
describe it to them
just describe it again
it's a big it's a big deal let me bring
it up yeah yeah yeah thank you jer it's
a big deal for
bobby's considered a club comic
by a lot of people because he has done
clubs for years that's where he mainly
performs so that